when you leave the pitch do you have a
good intuition about how it went
or is it like they could just love it
and you have no idea and then they're
not going to and then the opposite not I
you know it's we went through that I
mean we had the pitch and then we left
and we felt good about doing it and we
felt good about the way they responded
but their executives like their job is
to sort of like not give you anything
like that's you know like all executives
are probably really good at poker cuz
like that's their job they can't you
know they're not gonna say I'm not gonna
like open up a checkbook in the room
like this is great I wanna do that
there's like all kinds of checks and
balances that have to go on so they
can't really give you much of anything
except for you know undivided attention
so the pitch we had the executives came
in and there was undivided attention
like nobody was checking the phone
nobody was doing this
nobody had like other stuff they were
flipping through like it was us the
presentation and that and they were in
it and we were in it and that felt great
but you know the pitch ends and they go
this sounds great
send us the script we'll be in touch so
you leave so the good thing about that
is send us the script if you get people
to the point where they want to read
something you've done something right no
it was you know I mean so that's the
good thing that you pick up on but yeah
you drive yourself nuts trying to figure
out well you know the day thing what do
you think they said this word do you
drive yourself nuts you know you gotta
just kind of kind of rely on yourself
and how good you feel about what you're
doing what you did and then let the rest
of it fall and
broken record best thing for that have
more material because if you've got
other stuff you got one pitch with one
project but that's cool that doesn't fly
I got all this other cool stuff so again
all this
sorry Internet have more stuff you said
rely on yourself were you always that
self-reliant uh no probably not
I was more angry you know first script I
ever wrote I wrote because I was angry
at TV or watching something I don't even
remember what it was but I was like
seriously this is supposed to be comedy
this is crap did better than this
and that's how I wrote my first crap
smooth my first script was written out
of anger it was always like no I then
that evolved to sort of appreciating the
process of what happens you know what I
mean
it's weird like if you're working on a
show well at least when I was working on
the show it's like a kid straight out of
high school and pay a whole lot of
attention to the process you know I had
my job which was to play the role that I
had been hired to play say these lines
appropriately and then you know go hang
out with my friends I didn't know the
process of like the writers having to
sit with the showrunners and the
director and let's change this the
executives want this had to be in the
episode and you can't do that and we've
got all and pay attention to me of that
but you know you'd learn as you go and
then the first time you write something
the actual effort to actually write
something in itself is it's super easy
to be like that stupid well like that's
super easy but like nobody nobody sets
out to like make something stupid
like nobody's like all right you know
what here's what we're gonna do we're
making shitty
like that's her goal nobody does that
you know there's a process that you go
through and the process from your brain
to the screen just all kinds of stuff in
between that you not I mean so so no I
think I just think I just learned and I
got more comfortable with what I wanted
to say and I got more comfortable with
the way I said it I got more comfortable
with my own process of how I wrote you
know I tried all this stuff and it just
wasn't comfortable and I couldn't I
never finished anything but if I just
kind of let myself get lost in the story
I ended up with a story I just decided
well this is what works for me if it
sucks it sucks but I'm having fun I like
it having been a teenager and being in
the industry still being in it now do
you think you've been able to separate
the rejection from the work versus
they're rejecting you don't yeah I mean
I think everybody should live a year of
their life as an actor like everybody
just so that you can understand how
meaningless no is you know what I mean
anybody can say no to anything okay
great
there's like billions of other people
there's all kinds of other stuff going
on like everything you've seen somebody
said no to it probably several people
said no to it before you saw it there's
a thing that was on Twitter which I got
off of anyway is this thing on the
Twitter and it was like share your
stories oh rejection
yeah and you've got all of these writers
and actors and everybody was just like
you know I remember one guy was like I
sent my script to this festival and they
told me it was unfunny and unstructured
there was no focus and there was nothing
anybody could do with it it premieres
tonight starring Jim Carrey on show I
saw that tweet right I saw this thing
yeah it's awesome dude has gotten all of
that nonsense and been like oh well I
suck and ripped up the script we're done
you know what I mean who cares that that
person said no today I read it to you
yeah I think I read that that's so funny
it's like you're gonna hear no and then
you're gonna get back up and then you're
gonna do something else and maybe in the
know you hear something that teaches you
something or it doesn't who cares
whatever you keep going so and I think
acting is like that's all you do as an
actor is get told no no no no not you
okay no no no no no thank you now no and
then all of those people become stars
so yeah I think everybody should be an
actor for a year of their life just so
that they can understand the projection
is kind of pointless
you